dominique nachury monsieur le président
chers collègues ma question s'adresse à
madame la ministre de l'éducation
nationale madame la ministre c'est vrai
nous revenons souvent sur le sujet mais
la question et répéter parce qu'elle ne
reçoit aucune réponse argumentée la
réforme que vous proposez du collège a
suscité et suscite toujours de
nombreuses critiques que vous méprisez
elle appelle beaucoup d'éclaircissements
que vous n'apportez toujours pas et ce
n'est pas notre surdité ou notre
inattention mais bien votre attachement
aveugle à quelques concepts et votre
absence de vision pragmatique de l'état
réel du collège qui font que votre
réforme ne passe pas les enseignements
pratiques interdisciplinaire et
l'accompagnement personnalisé sont mal
appréhendé le service partagé pose
problème dans les petits établissements
des inégalités territoriales sont créées
notamment au regard des classes
bilangues et pointe le risque d'
ajustement des moyens des lycées pour
permettre la mise en oeuvre de la
réforme du collège madame la ministre
vous avez dit à marseille récemment
qu'il était essentiel qui existait soit
écouté des lanceurs d'alert qui
connaissant le terrain interpellent les
responsables
alors pourquoi êtes-vous sourde aux
enseignants inquiets et qui envisagent
de boycotter surveillance correction
d'examens et conseils de classe ou
encore d'entrer en résistance
pédagogique
pourquoi ils vous sourde aux parents
d'élèves qui dans tous les coins de
france sont nombreux à signer des appels
contre votre les réformes
madame la ministre vous comptez sans
doute sur la résignation et la lassitude
des enseignants des parents de tous les
acteurs de l'éducation
mais pensez vous vraiment que cela
suffirait à donner à votre réforme les
qualités qui lui manque il à répondre
aux exigences de niveau et de formation
des collégiens merci la parole est à
madame najat vallaud belkacem ministre
de l'éducation nationale de
l'enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche
merci monsieur le président mais
vous aimez sur les députés madame la
députée nage furie merci d'avoir évoqué
marseille car c'est en effet une très
belle illustration de ce que nous sommes
capables de faire lorsque nous prenons
les sujets au sérieux pour changer et
notamment le sujet de l'école car oui il
n'était pas acceptable que dans une
ville de cette taille autant d'enfants à
et dans des écoles délabrées
alors oui nous avons décidé d'intervenir
avec fermeté et en même temps dans le
dialogue avec la ville de marseille et
enfin enfin nous en sommes à faire les
travaux qui aurait dû être fait depuis
des années parce que la ville de
marseille certes a accepté d'y mettre
quelques moyens mais aussi parce que
l'état avec sa politique de la ville et
je remercie patrick kanner a accepté
d'en mettre aussi c'est au fond
l'illustration de tout ce que nous
faisons en matière d'éducation je
pourrais prendre les deux minutes qui me
sont accordés pour vous répondre à
nouveau en quoi va consister à la
réforme du collège mais honnêtement
cette question vous me l'avez poser
souvent je crois vous à pouvoir apporter
toutes les réponses donc vous verrez à
la rentrée prochaine lorsque cette
réforme du collège endarra en vigueur
avec tous les établissements s'y prépare
qu'elle est faite dans l'intérêt des
enfants
mais je vais vous répondre plus
généralement madame la députée puisque
la réussite scolaire de nos élèves
partout sur le territoire semble vous
intéresser je vais vous répondre avec
avec quelques rappels
qu'avons nous trouver lorsque nous
sommes arrivés en 2012 en matière et de
monsieur cochet à mesure aujourd'hui en
2012 nous avons trouvé 140 me
décrocheurs parents nous en sommes à
cent dix mille aujourd'hui en 2012
nous avons trouvé des professeurs qui
n'était plus fort mais nous en sommes
aujourd'hui à des forts professeurs qui
sont enfin former en formation initiale
et en formation continue
en 2012 nous avons trouvé une éducation
prioritaire qui n'avait pas été réformé
depuis 30 ans avec des injustices
flagrantes et du saupoudrage inefficace
nous l'avons réformer les établissements
sont enfin accompagner en 2012 vous
supprimiez un prof à chaque fois qu'on
avait huit élèves de plus
aujourd'hui nous
créons un pour cinq élèves surcouche
madame la députée vous n'avez pas de
leçons à nous donner flers
merci madame la ministre la part